- I've been doing drag for
about three and a half years,
sounds about right, three or four years.
At first I started doing it
as just for fun or a little
hobby of mine, and
somehow it became serious.
(upbeat music)
Coming out to my family
wasn't as hard as it is
to other people cause I
kind of knew they were gonna
accept me but it was just
hard because I didn't want
them to feel like I was a failure.
And my father I haven't
told him to the day
I haven't told him yet,
but I'm sure he knows
I feel like sometimes you
don't really have to actually
tell the person that you're gay.
It's just something that
they know and they're okay
with and you could see
it through their actions
or the way they talk to you.
(electronic music)
I'm first generation
Latino, well my dad is from
Jalisco, and my mom is from Mexicali.
My drag character is more
like dark and mesmerizing.
And when I'm not doing
that my other side is my
Latina side where I incorporate
just music that I listen
to also with my outfits I
love to incorporate my culture
and bring all that in, because
I am proud of my culture,
I think it's beautiful to be a Latino.
Drag is just art.
For me it's just art.
A way of self expression
cause I still think of myself
as a man.
It doesn't change just
because I'm a drag queen
or I'm queer.
(electronic music)
(applause)
(calm music)
Even though in my culture
men are perceived as more
strong, more confident
beings, it's funny that I get
in drag because I feel like
a woman is more confident
and more powerful.
In the Latin communities
the man is the head of the
household, but the woman is
the one who holds the balls.
(laughing)
In a way I feel like she's stronger.
I saw that growing up with my mother.
Like she'll do anything for her kids.
Hearing stories of my brothers and sisters
in Latin America and other
countries being attacked
and raped for being who they
are really makes me think
how fortunate I am to be
born in United States.
It makes me think that if my
parents wouldn't have moved
here, I don't think I'll
be feeling comfortable
enough to be doing drag or
stepping out of the house
with a wig on.
(somber music)
People here still like look at me and
take a second look when
they see me walking by.
The difference is that it
doesn't matter to me here
cause although something
could happen to me
I just don't care.
(somber music)
And that's why I just feel
like when I hear those
stories it just makes me not take anything
for granted and be so thankful
for having been born here.
And the struggles that my
parents went through to
get me here.
And that's why part of me
still wants to incorporate
my culture in my drag
cause I'm so proud of it
and it's something that
makes me truly happy
to put it out there and let everybody know
that I'm a Latino and I feel unstoppable.
(somber music)